people here say that they could see
bodies literally dropping from the skies
huge passenger jet coming down in the
middle of a war zone that's gonna be a
big story it didn't seem like a real
situation it's being a tall I've just
never seen so many dead people
[Music]
it was unbelievable I've been in Israel
would you believe and and I was waiting
to go into Gaza we were doing a live
shot when suddenly this news broke
break-in used to bring you the Reuters
news agency reporting that a Malaysian a
passenger aeroplane has crashed in
Ukraine Oh Cameron said to me this NH 17
is crash it's very unlucky and I said
that's not unlucky that's been shot down
it was rumoured that the plane had been
shot down by a surface-to-air missile
that kind of thing doesn't happen every
day well try and find out more details
from the scene I was working in the sky
newsroom that day I think initially we
all thought well this must be a mistake
it can't be a passenger jet it's it's a
military aircraft for so many weeks we'd
had reports of Ukrainian aircraft being
shot at by pro-russian separatists in
that exact region but as the reports
continued to come in we realized that
actually it was much bigger than that
so the newsroom becomes this kind of
frenetic place people are running around
trying to make sure that we're getting
this story on air correctly reporting
the facts hundreds of passengers are
feared dead after a Malaysian Airlines
jet crashed in Ukraine there are claims
the plane may have been shot down with
both Ukrainian government and
pro-russian separatists denying
responsibility our foreign desk really
springs into action the key job that
they have to do is make sure we've got
people on the ground we've got the call
to go to Ukraine
weirdly Ukraine on Israel have so many
flights you couldn't you couldn't you
know you couldn't imagine how many
flights there are nobody else to get to
Ukraine but we did we jumped on the
plane that evening seven hours later
we're at the crash site
they were going to have to send a big
deployment multiple teams multiple
people to go and report this story I
kind of stuck my hand up and said look I
can go right away you can see was gonna
be a massive story a huge passenger jet
at Boeing triple7 coming down in the
middle of a war zone that's gonna be a
big story we navigated our own way and
eventually saw some debris in the field
I came over the hill of a corn field and
at the bottom I could see wreckage
burning I said to Pete this is still on
fire we saw it's unbelievable
we didn't expect to get anywhere near
the epicenter of the crash site we were
I think just mesmerised that we actually
got there and then with what we were
faced with we were so fresh on the
ground less than 24 hours after the
plane had come down all the bodies were
we're still lying there compared to
other stories I've done of natural
disasters and war zones this this was
high up there
everywhere I look the bodies I mean just
heads and arms and legs and young
children and suitcases and and just
people everywhere every step in trees
tops of houses is staggering and I think
that's absolutely staggering I've just
never seen so many dead people in one
place at any at just one time
to be kind of launched into the middle
of a crash site of a huge passenger
plane
it just blew both of our minds we saw
such a catastrophic incident that as the
plane broke up people here say that they
could see bodies literally dropping from
the skies
[Music]
I was filming Stuart in the what was the
wings section and that where the engines
are
he could smell bodies you could smell
death
[Music]
you saw parts of aircraft stood around
the countryside and then obviously
people's personal effects
and then you pull up actually to the
main crash site itself which is enormous
they're still pulling bodies out of the
crash line
[Music]
none of it seemed real it didn't seem
like a real situation to being at all
there we were stood right on the middle
of the main croissant there were
probably 20-30 body stretching ahead of
us
[Music]
horrendous
the debris field I think is the is the
term they used was very large we were at
one end at the debris field but it went
back a long long way in the whole way
through fields after fields and roads
after rosin body just ever way you long
the access to the crash zone was
absolutely incredible it wouldn't happen
in the UK or anywhere else in the
Western world but there we were right on
the edge of this major crash site where
a passenger jet had fallen from the sky
there was no order whatsoever there were
military there but there was no one
actually preventing us from from doing
anything it's just totally serene
nothing was cordoned off everything
could be accessed and seen and genuinely
you were standing in amongst this
wreckage we walked through a bit of a
track out into the field itself and
suddenly opened up into an area will the
crops were flattened there ahead of us
basically was the front of the part of
the aircraft
who's there very obviously the the
cockpit and the business car section you
can see the pilot seats you can see all
the avionics you can see cables and
control panels just strewn everywhere
there was paperwork there was flight
logs and briefcases with the details of
that day's flight on it all these items
that made the thing incredibly human so
poignant and so sad in the wreckage you
saw the actual handwritten note that
their captain would have said over the
tunnel
it's not where do we was we - I had
never seen anything like it on the hands
of the wheel of the in the coping with
her hands of the the guy who had been
flying a plane and we did a piece the
camera it Pete says we can't use this
and wait since our hand it's still on
the wheel
[Music]
I've never been in a situation like this
before you know I've been in war zones
many times and I've been to smaller
plane crashes but I've never been to a
large plane crash in the middle of a war
zone behind me I can hear you won't be
able to hear it but there's a grad
missile launcher that has been firing
pretty much every 10 minutes for the
last few hours there is a battle taking
place a few kilometers away we're in the
middle of a war but it was fighting
going on all around us while we were
looking at this huge graves all you
could hear was the boom of artillery
I must confess I really wasn't thinking
about the the danger aspects of it I
wasn't thinking about that being an
active pretty hairy war zone the area of
the crash there were some flower fields
and cornfields and locals has
effectively brought a white flag on a
stick marking a body or part of a body
I remember seeing that local people have
come from nearby towns and villages
there was a group of coal miners who'd
come to help with the recovery efforts
we pulled up it's a field where we saw a
lot of activity and basically it was
people doing a long line search through
the crops and it was quite extraordinary
it was a beautiful picture if you like
because the crops are so pretty in the
sunlight but you know that they're
actually looking for bodies and every
time they found a body they'd put a
stick in the ground with a little white
piece of material on it and that would
mark the body that will stay with me
[Music]
it took a really long time for the
repatriation to get underway first they
had to account for all of the victims
and then transport them from the crash
site
to Ukrainian friendly territory and that
was where they were going to be flown on
their final journey home
[Music]
so the first time that the bodies were
actually dealt with with any sort of
dignity
they were handed over and then
everything kind of slowed down and
bodies were calmly
loaded onto the back of the transport
planes it was almost like a military
funeral very very respectful
[Music]
when a Plane full of women men children
who were probably just going on holiday
shot out of the sky by a myth harlot
that should not have happened
I think that was really difficult to
process and I really hope I don't never
have to cover a story like that again
why they would want to shoot a passenger
jet down I do not know the only thing I
can think is that it was unintentional
military jets and helicopters have been
shot down but why they would suddenly
then want to start targeting a passenger
jet I just I just don't understand
there was a major investigation and that
found that the missile system used to
shoot down the airliner had to come from
Russia but of course the Russians deny
that and the whole thing just goes on
and on it was only when you started to
think about the families and and
everything that they had gone through
it's quite stressful
[Music]
my sympathy would go to the obviously
the families who have not got closure
yet I just hope that comes soon
[Music]
[Applause]